dr. ho test we've been talking about
this is a moral trade-off there are also
burdens public health systems do we have
any sense of what the current outbreak
is going to cost well you're absolutely
right this is not only as measles one of
the leading killers of children in the
world before we started practicing
widespread vaccination in the United
States we were looking at 500 deaths
annually in 50,000 hospitalizations you
can do the math that's a lot of dollars
as well so measles is going to have not
only a significant public health impact
it's also going to have a significant
economic impact the other economic
factor that we have to consider is
remember now if you're a young mother or
parent living in Marin County California
or if you're living in Orange County
California you have to be very fearful
about bringing your young baby is not
old enough to get immunized against
measles outside out in the public so
she's going to remain shuttered he's
going to remain shuddered in the house
this is going to be a big deal dr. ho
does yesterday our Twitter question the
day was we asked whether or not people
thought the government should be able to
force you to vaccinate your children it
was we had a stunning response and far
more responses than we ever get and
essentially the gist of the critics was
that why should you care if I don't get
my kid vaccinated if you get your kid
vaccinated we're trying to keep our
opinions out of this but how would you
respond to that I'm of the opinion that
we should not allow unvaccinated
children into our schools I think that
that's it's too much it's too dangerous
to the other children in the school you
know people talk about this is a civil
liberties issue I flip that around the
other way when Thomas Jefferson wrote
the Declaration of Independence he
talked about right to liberty and
happiness and and the mothers and
parents of children now in these
affected counties can't go outside they
have their rights to privacy dr. Hodes
has you are too humble you have dealt
directly with this with your family
correct me if I'm wrong but you've
provided leadership on autism from your
home and from your personal experience
you more than anyone in this nation can
discuss this mad
this linking your medicine to your
family struggle with autism no one can
speak like Peter ota's well thanks for
that yeah it's a more more my wife
that's borne the brunt of it but our
youngest daughter is an adult now whose
severe autism and other developmental
disabilities and another free for decade
for more than a decade now have been
going out in public and saying autism is
very tough on families it's brutal but
guess what it's not related to vaccines
this is a genetic or epigenetic disease
a spectrum of disorders and the idea
that a vaccine could cause autism is not
even plausible scientifically and it's
only slowly now that people are coming
around to this doctor hotels one of the
things that we're learning about this
debate is that it's becoming it's coming
to resemble the debate over global
warming in which one side says well we
have empirics peer-reviewed science on
our side and the other side says I don't
care let me read you something from a
bloomberg news story yesterday it's a
quote from a public health official if
you insult people or you disrespect
people you can harden their perspectives
the doctor has you've been talking to
the anti-vaccination movement for a very
long time what is the right way to have
this debate well that's a great question
i think the the important point to point
out is that these are deadly diseases
these are not diseases that we can
trifle with that we can mess with having
a hundred cases now measles and this
outbreak is very scary we're going to
reach the point soon where we're going
to start seeing some deaths for measles
of young children and and that's a very
sobering lesson to have to let it go
this far so this is this is an entirely
preventable outbreak dr. ho des I want
to draw your attention to an opp had
written by a Tom Frieden the director of
the CDC and time he writes quote measles
is so remarkably infectious that you
can't protect yourself you can get it
just from being in a space where a
person not yet very ill with measles
left two hours ago or in an auditorium
with just one measles patient many seats
away from you I believe the official
number right now stands just a little
over 100 confirmed cases of measles in
the US do you think right now we're
what about a tipping point where this
becomes in broader epidemic well if you
remember you had me on the show a couple
of months ago and I for explain to you
why I do not think Ebola will take off
in the United States well for every
reason I don't think Ebola would ever
take off in the United States I have
every reason to believe measles will
this is more than a dozen times more
infectious it's also a disease where you
become infectious before your
symptomatic so you could have some day
looks perfectly normal and they're
shedding measles virus into the
environment and this is one of the most
transmissible infectious agents that we
know about and it spreads like wildfire
and until we vaccinated the US
population this was one of the great
killers of children in the United States
dr. does real quick was were running out
of time we have learned that clusters
are very dangerous that even a very
small cluster of parents that don't
vaccinate can can help the disease
incubate how do you approach that
clustering problem as a public health
issue the only way is to get that
population vaccinated to get them into
their pediatrician and get them clicking
doses of the measles vaccine okay doctor
has I have a sinking feeling we're gonna
have to talk to you very often in the
future but it's a pleasure thank you